estamos en comunicación esta tarde con
el director regional del centro
internacional de investigación para el
desarrollo de canadá es un centro
internacional canadiense federico burone
está en sus oficinas en uruguay que tal
federico como elevar bueno me va muy
bien y un placer de estar contigo y toda
la audiencia gracias me gustaría que
comencemos hablando de esta nueva
estrategia la estrategia 2030 del ser
servei y por sus siglas en francés
cuéntenos de qué manera de forma general
en qué consiste esta nueva estrategia
para el 2030 que el pse entonces
establecido recientemente perfecto bueno
el centro es un centro que se
especializa en
apoyar el uso de las capacidades
científicas la investigación como un
insumo para los cambios las
transformaciones la innovación en
ámbitos en desarrollo hemos identificado
dos grandes desafíos globales que están
muy presentes y que continuarán estando
presente en los próximos años la agenda
de cambio climático y la necesidad de
continuar reduciendo las brechas de
desigualdad nuestra nueva estrategia se
enfoca a dar respuesta en cada contexto
según las necesidades de cada sociedad a
estos dos grandes desafíos
efectivamente federico esos dos puntos
creo que han sido además en el caso de
la pandemia de eso que estamos viviendo
la desigualdad las desigualdades que se
viven en el mundo han sido evidentes ya
y ha sido evidente también los efectos
que una crisis como la actual puede
tener
en poblaciones vulnerables en
poblaciones que viven
desproporcionadamente la pobreza o
desproporcionadamente los cambios
climáticos entonces ahora nos hablan más
en particular de este aspecto de la
desigualdad de qué manera las
investigaciones que ustedes están
apoyando podrán ir en ese sentido en
comprender mejor esas desigualdades ya
lo mejor encontrar soluciones porque no
perfecto si las brechas las brechas de
desigualdad como como estamos están
indicando han sido fuertemente
impactadas por esta pandemia además de
lo que ya veníamos observando que es una
dificultad para reducirlas en el
contexto en particular a nivel global
pero muy especialmente en américa latina
a pesar de los esfuerzos las inversiones
los nuevos programas
enfoque social protección y empleo
general
oportunidades algo todavía no estaba
funcionando y ahora se ha grabado con el
efecto de la pandemia tenemos grandes
brechas de desigualdad tenemos sectores
muy extensos en todas las poblaciones de
los países de américa latina que no
logran concluir los ciclos de educación
más básicos que no logran acceder a la
salud en sus enfoques más primarios
preventivos que no logran generar las
habilidades necesarias para insertarse
de alguna forma en un medio de vida
incluso en los mercados laborales de
carácter informal y que por supuesto
transmiten generacionalmente todas esas
debilidades vulnerabilidades en forma
y no permitir una cierta ascensión
progresión en el desarrollo de
sociedades más igualitarias necesitamos
entender las razones y las razones
parece desde una óptica regional que son
comunes pero en cada sociedad hay
aspectos muy particulares culturales
con composición de la población
violencia que de alguna forma se expresa
contra sectores de la población
género mujeres otras identidades
sexuales
tenemos resolver en forma sistémica de
lo contrario no lograremos este
progresar o avanzar y en esa dirección
dirigiremos nuestra programación en los
próximos años
y para el caso de américa latina- esto
fue como la visión más general porque
tenemos que decir que el centro
internacional de investigación para el
desarrollo de canadá tiene proyectos en
todo el mundo particularmente en las
regiones menos favorecidas digamos por
la situación económica política o
ambiental pero para américa latina que
es lo que se tiene previsto que haya
enfoques específicos para américa latina
o países específicos donde la
investigación estará dirigida estamos en
plena discusión y decisión en ese
sentido pero algunas algunas pistas
puedo adelantarte
quizás la primera tiene que ver con la
pandemia nos ha enseñado que debemos
continuar buscando y entendiendo cuáles
son justamente los sectores
poblacionales que están más en riesgo en
caso de que este tipo de
infecciones que están ligadas a un mal
uso de los recursos naturales y una mala
comprensión de cómo funcionan las
actividades humanas dentro de un
ecosistema más amplio los primeros en
este caso en que pagan las consecuencias
son sectores poblacionales más
directamente expuestos
estaremos anunciando en pocos días más
una iniciativa convocando a a nivel
global pero que tiene prioridad también
en américa latina' a tratar de entender
cuáles son los ámbitos en los que este
tipo de fenómenos pueden volver a
ocurrir y de qué forma podemos juntar
esfuerzos de distintos actores para
tener un enfoque preventivo ya no
esperar a que tengamos nuevamente un
problema soluciones en el sentido de
generar estas capacidades entendimiento
para prevenir este tipo de temas estamos
trabajando fuertemente también con
diálogos entre el sector público y el
sector privado actores del sector
privado
qué nuevo acuerdo podemos generar en
américa latina donde el empleo cuando se
genera y el vínculo de los empleados con
una empresa
fortalezca el valor que la sociedad le
da a esa empresa esto que suena un poco
extraño es un fenómeno que vemos que
está creciendo en particular en américa
latina' las empresas buscan que sus
esfuerzos en la gestión del ambiente en
generar condiciones de empleo dignas
también formen parte de su capital
empresarial y también formen parte del
reconocimiento de sus consumidores de
productos o servicios sí porque yo he
visto que aquí en canadá hay eyes ha
habido en los últimos años una cuestión
relacionada con la legislación y en la
cuestión relacionada con la
responsabilidad social de las empresas
canadienses en el extranjero entonces me
imagino que va en esta misma en esta
misma vía de realmente evaluar qué es lo
que funciona qué es lo que no funciona
cómo está funcionando el hecho de que
una empresa se haga responsable de lo
que su producción y su existencia misma
deja de jaén el ambiente social 14
fíjate que en canadá ha sido muy
interesante observar como el apoyo desde
el gobierno al sector empresarial en
esta fase crítica para intentar generar
los pilares de la recuperación económica
después durante la crisis de kobe esas
transferencias esos acuerdos han estado
también ligados a la necesidad de pensar
e implementar transformaciones desde el
punto de vista ambiental respuestas a la
agenda de cambio climático reducción de
las emisiones de carbono eso está muy
lejos eso está muy lejos de lo que
estamos observando en américa latina
pero está muy lejos quizás porque no
tenemos las condiciones o nos preocupa
agregar algún elemento adicional a las
dificultades que el sector empresarial
en este momento está confrontando
nosotros estamos haciendo programación
en américa latina' y mirando estos
ejemplos innovadores en canadá y quizás
otros contextos y tratando también de
acercar esos mundos
de generar diálogo de perder ciertos
miedos a las transformaciones que son
sin dudas necesarias esa es nuestra
misión para los próximos 10 años
federico burone director regional del
centro internacional de investigación
para el resto para el desarrollo de
canadá
muchas gracias por esta entrevista para
radio canadá internacional
un placer un abrazo para todos o
invierno si ya estamos de salida eso
esperamos
gracias federico
[Música]